apple is particularly um
sharp elbow should i say with people who
compete with them they know they do it
with a smile on their face but
the the bane of my existence is that
fitbit and my health
product apple health kit or apple health
and fitbit don't play nicely i bought a
third-party tool i spent 10 bucks on it
to try to get these things to sync it
always breaks it it doesn't work
yours seems to work pretty good with
apple but you're not making a watch
yeah and i'm curious
is your relationship really good with
apple because you don't make a watch
and how do you think about your
relationships with the googles
you know and the apples of the world
which have said hey we're going to own
health they both have said that
fitbit's getting bought by google
apparently yeah and they want to own
health
apple wants to own health how does that
how do you navigate that as a founder
i'm curious
so i i mean one i think we play nicely
with both of them you know we
distribute the apps on their app stores
we actually integrate with both
you know apple health and google fit um
so i think we were like you know let's
let's be open and neutral
um and in that sense i think you know
we're partners right
right um i i think because of our view
first really on sleep
and our focus there as a company you
know we found it complementary just like
you
are wearing a fitbit and you have an
aura ring we see that with so many apple
watch works
right um and so i think for us what
percentage of aura wearers
have a watch ball apple watch don't know
the exact numbers off the top
gotta be one a third half probably i'd
assume a third
yeah maybe i would think so because you
know when you're elite enough
and well healed enough to afford a watch
that's eight hundred dollars or six
hundred dollars you're going to be able
to afford the aura for two or three or
three or four
and they are complimentary they don't
compete with each other which leads me
to the next question
is which is better overall to wear a
watcher to wear
a ring and why is there some difference
between what's being collected or are
they both
just really great ways to record is
there is your
ring finger better than your wrist or
yeah so the pulse the pulse signal from
your finger
is about 100 times two orders of
magnitude stronger than the rest
really i assume the opposite that's so
interesting well every hospital where do
they measure your heart rate in your
spo2
yeah they do it on the chip of your
finger yeah so it turns out you know how
you can feel these arteries on the
inside of your wrist
right you know it's a lot of blood there
you can feel that pulse you can't feel
your pulse on the back side of your
watch it's
those arteries go to the palm of your
hand what's what's interesting their
skin is super thin
those arteries are close to the surface
that pulse signal then is two you know
100 times stronger
as a result so that's something i i
actually worked on in college got to
mess around with some optics right and
and and wearables and so that's that's
why i think for us that's so important
so when you start training this data
i'll give you an example right now we
record you know we've said this before
on podcasts we actually sample at 250
hertz
the 250 times we're finding our leds per
second right to get the shape of that
pulse waveform
we do that eight hours a night right for
about six nights right
if you took the apple watch and put it
250 hertz or a fitbit or anything
it would die in about an hour because
the pulse signal's so much weaker
right and so the battery life would
would go put and so as a result
we're able to capture higher fidelity
data you know i think there's a reason
why our kova data stood out amongst so
many
you know why you know both the nba the
wnba ufc
nascar red bull racing las vegas sans um
you know have have chosen to use our
product and our algorithm there i think
you'll see some new stuff coming on the
road for us from
you know um from actually on just sleep
staging itself
updating our algorithm to to even more
accurate the best
that's out there in the field and i
think you know we're going to show that
with this high fidelity data we can
create algorithms that are just a cut
above the rest
and so you know while we started on
sleep um and we think it's
perhaps the most single important thing
and how you start every day we all arise
from sleep every day
you know your day starts out of sleep
you know i think there's a lot more
we're going to be doing in total health
as we as we get into the future
um the ring right now is
not super bulky but it's not super thin
i have to take it off as an example when
i type
because i'm a fast touch typist um do
you see the ring getting thinner
or staying the same and including more
objects and then
have you thought about any kind of
embeddable technology
and and if not when do you think
embeddable technology will happen i'm
not talking about
you know neural link in your brain but
it does seem to me that if
this works this well why can't i put
something into the palm of my hand
have it surgically implemented and you
know have a
long life battery that you know gives me
even more data
yeah um so i think uh on the latter
you know that's an expensive procedure
more expensive than you think
even if you go today to get a loop
recorder right which
bedside can do you don't need to go
under to do that and they implant a
little
you know little chip and right
underneath the skin you know on top of
where you're underneath the skin on top
of your heart that's like a four or five
thousand dollar
cost really yeah yeah yeah uh if you
look at i think the medicare
reimbursement codes for that
how different is that heart rate to
everything else in the market like
watches and rings and everything
i mean yeah i mean what we showed though
is actually our heart rate and our heart
rate variability overnight for every
single heartbeat we're 99
i think point six percent correlated
with an ekg overnight
so we're getting pretty damn close so
there goes it's sort of like cameras you
know people
i remember talking to sergey brin about
cameras 10 years ago and he was carrying
a digital slr and
he asked me like what do you think a
digital a phone camera is going to be
able to do or digital sr will be able to
do that phone camera and i was like well
i don't think about this and this and he
was like
nothing the software and the algorithms
are going to make cameras
and phones as good as and they're going
to get rid of digital slrs only people
with digital slrs are going to
you know and he's right i mean you can
do all these cool i mean every year we
get like a couple more
low light the blur effect behind you all
that stuff just gets better and better
so
yeah i guess that's what it is right the
algorithms of the software
make up for the lack of fidelity of the
sensor
yeah i think it's think about it this
way you know on any given week at aura
we see more data on sleep you know just
take take half a million users i'm just
throwing a number out there because we
you know publicly said we've sold a half
million rings now
times seven you know seven nights that's
300 you know
that's that's a lot of nights right 3.5
million nights right so um
that's more than any all the sleep labs
in america combined in a given week
in one single place right so that
fidelity that data that you're starting
to get as you start to aggregate more
and more
is super helpful and those insights then
can be obviously really really rich so
i think data you know data is the new
currency
right and so i think there's there's a
lot there you can do and you can keep
training and seeing
you know patterns in that data so yeah i
think um
i want to get back to one of your other
questions so you know do we think you
can get thinner
yes and smaller yes and you know i think
also we've seen some people want
bigger designs more you know more
fashion looking design so i think
you know i think you'll see us flex our
muscles a bit there in both directions
here comes the skew craziness yes
i mean i know that steve jobs would be
absolutely losing his mind over the
number of uh
apple watch skus it was like
oh my god we got how many sizes how many
styles how many
cr i mean crowns it just got so crazy
but i guess in this world you know
you are a fashion accessory and this
do you have any brand partnerships with
um you know a gucci or a prada
or some tiffany or something and people
approached you about that yet or no
we've seen interest from all of them
really yeah fascinating
so i think you know i think you know how
we do that how you figured out as a
brand right apple
went and partnered who was it with
hermes yeah for the for the
for the wristband or man i think at one
point did a partnership with like
tory burch if i'm not i can't even
remember yeah i feel like the
handles but i mean a really cool ring
that
i got the one with the flat top i don't
know what that's
called yeah for some reason i thought it
looked cooler than just round
yeah i like the flat top i like the
heritage too that's our most popular
version oh is it yeah i wonder if people
are going to use these as wedding rings
right we've already seen it we've
already found oh really yeah in fact we
we get a lot of angry wives because
they're like
my husband won't wear his wedding ring
but now he's wearing an oar ring like
yeah oh boy but you're in trouble now
just wear it on your wedding rings the
same thing i mean yeah
and can you get them engraved i didn't
notice we haven't done that we haven't
done any engravings yet
um you know i think that's actually one
two yeah that could be pretty cool
the the options are endless but to your
point you know steve jobs had
had a point you don't want too many skew
blow right so i think
there's there's always those those
trade-offs you got to figure out as a
company